aujourd'hui les députés ont adopté à
l'unanimité une résolution permettant la
publicité de certaines auditions à
l'Assemblée nationale une résolution
déposée par Laurent Fabius l'un des
premiers signes de la marque que le
jeune président de l'Assemblée nationale
souhaite imprimer une image plus moderne
et plus ouverte Philippe
devski si Jacques chabandelmass avait
assuré le ravalement extérieur du Palais
Bourbon laurophabus s'atêle lui au
dépoussiéragees intern celui qui est le
plus jeune président du Parlement de
puis Gambetta a reçu la charge de
François mitéran de redonner à
l'Assemblée nationale sa place un
pouvoir plus respecté par l'exécutif une
image plus positive dans l'opinion
Premier ministre Laurent Fabius pouvait
paraître aux yeux de certains comme un
jeune homme un peu trop pressé
aujourd'hui il avance prudemment après
sa brillante élection au perchoir en
juin dernier il vient de réussir sa
première étape pour moderniser
l'Assemblée en faisant voter à
l'unanimité des députés un texte
permettant la publicité des débats des
commissions parlementaires comme cela
existe aux États-Unis ce dont on a
absolument besoin c'est de changer nos
méthodes de travail pour qu'il y ait
moins d'absentéisme pour que euh on se
rende compte de la qualité du travail
qui est fait ici et pour que vraiment
euh on soit à l'unisson des soucis
quotidiens des Français si on arrive à
faire cela l'image de l'assemblée sera
meilleure qu'elle est aujourd'hui
Laurent Fabius veut aussi réformer les
questions orales au gouvernement
retransmis sur FR3 chaque mercredi
après-midi durant les sessions au
députés il leur demande d'être plus
fairplay au ministre de moins dérober
les débat PEV être vifs ça c'est normal
mais il faut le respect de la fonction
et au printemps nous allons prendre une
nouvelle initiative c'est-à-dire qu'il
va y avoir une nouvelle séance de
questions mais qui sera différente qui
viendra en complément on passera au
crible si je peux dire un ministère
probablement chaque semaine et par une
alternance de questions et de réponse
très rapide et donc on pourra ainsi
mieux contrôler le gouvernement et
préparer peut-être la session budgétaire
qui a Liu à l'ut
l'objectif donc rationaliser le travail
parlementaire dans une atmosphère de
respect mutuel et cela pour permettre au
députés d'avoir plus d'initiativ
législativ des initiatives que les
gouvernements successifs de la 5e
République avaient eu trop tendance à
s'arroger il y a 20 ans Jacques
chabandelm avait tenté cette même
Révolution il avait échoué aujourd'hui
Laurent Fabius relève le
défi